so that's two Milestones the first
Milestone is the one I just mentioned
it's the largest percent increase
we've ever seen in the ITP the other
Milestone is the first time we've ever
seen
a pair of drugs that used together gives
you a greater percentage increase than
either drug used by itself and to a
significant extent so hello and welcome
to the cheeky science show where in this
video I spoke with Richard Miller
professor of pathology at the University
of Michigan and the director of
Michigan's Paul F Glenn Center for
biology of Aging research he's also a
lead driver behind the interventions
testing program where they study the
effects of various Strokes on lifespan
and mice here we discuss further the ITP
study as well as his Labs Research into
understanding the mechanism of Aging I
hope you enjoy our conversation
so hi Rich thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the cheeky Science
Show I'm pleased to be here
well thank you
um so I thought before we go into some
of your recent uh research it'd be very
interesting for my audience to hear a
bit about maybe your introduction into
the science
that is in my personal reasons for
getting you to science is that the
question
I'm for sure yeah that and we'll say
maybe touch upon some of your earlier
research I know you did some work on the
immune system
sure yeah um so when I was I don't know
10 or 11 or 12 years old it occurred to
me that getting old was a really rotten
idea people tend to get sick and then
they died and none of that sounded like
fun so it occurred to me the smart thing
to do would be to learn how to slow the
aging process so that people including
myself most importantly could live a
long time and be disease-free I became a
scientist and always wanted to work on
nothing except the aging process when I
was ready to do a postdoc I knew I had
to get a job eventually so I decided to
learn so Immunology figuring that no one
wanted to hire you if you were working
on Aging but a lot of people would hire
you if you wanted to work on immunity so
I started to look at age Associated
changes in the immune system and I
worked on that for 10 or 15 years the
more and more I got into that the more I
became convinced that it was interesting
stuff and a lot was being learned part
of it by my lab but the the real payoff
was going to come from looking at things
in slowed the aging process in 1996
Andre vartke published the first paper
showing that a single gene mutation
could extend lifespan in mice by 35 or
40 percent it had already been known for
a long time that calorification could do
even better than that so the basic goal
of the lab since about that time has
been to see
how these genes slow aging how the
diet's slow aging and eventually to find
drugs that also slowed aging that's now
the central focus of the lab is common
biochemical and endocrinological and
physiological Pathways that slow aging
regardless of whether the intervention
is genetic or dietary or pharmacological
about 15 percent of the lab tries to
cheat by using natural selection that is
we have fibroblasts from long and shorts
of birds and long short-lived rodents
and long and shortlist primates and we
often will do a survey study saying hey
does this enzyme characteristically go
up if you have a long-lived animal in
any one of these independent clades if
the answer is yes and we've sort of
discovered half a dozen of those then we
can ask well okay if you have a slow
aging Mouse
is it because that enzyme has changed we
can use the comparative biology part of
the lab as a way of getting leads on
targets that drugs or genes might use in
an individual species like mice to slow
the aging process down so that's that's
a sort of an overview of
why I abandoned Immunology to devote
myself full-time to biogeratology
yeah that was a great overview and I'm
sure we'll we'll go back through some of
those topics you've already mentioned
but obviously one thing that's kind of
um been a a core of your research has
been working with mice and so um
obviously a lot of people talk about how
translatable is research and mice to
humans but I just thought firstly why
why am I is what makes mice a good model
um
um what is the yeah what why are they
commonly used oh mice are the best
obviously clearly and dramatically the
best you've probably noticed that worms
and flies don't look like us at all and
a lot of our hormones they don't have a
lot of our organs they don't have a lot
of our neural processes they don't have
mice have all of them with the exception
of the part of our brains that are good
at doing calculations and getting
Alzheimer's mindset everything we've got
uh and uh you could do it humans humans
would be even better except that you'd
have to live four or six four five or
six hundred years to get an experiment
done in humans so mice are the exactly
right sweet spot they're so much like
humans that a lot of the time things
that are true in mice are also true in
humans and vice versa
I'm I'm not I'm sort of tongue-in-cheek
I read all the more literature all the
fly literature and I pay attention to it
because very often they will make
discoveries that uh Point attention to
things one really ought to look at in
mice
um if you investigate 10 of those leads
then you'll find two or three things
that are really important mice that's a
very nice percentage
I'm much much more oppressed by 10 to 20
or 30 percent crossover hit rates than I
am by zero percent so the work they've
done is highly influential even though
most of it does not apply to humans or
lice
enough of it does
and um I guess I might also incredibly
important for the intervention testing
program
um so I thought maybe it'd be
interesting to hear the kind of origin
story of how this um I mean fussy what
is the Interventional starting program
but also how the idea initiated sure
um Huber Warner who was at that time the
director of the biology program at the
national aging Institute about 20 years
ago put together a working group of some
people who worked on mice some that
worked on invertebrate models uh a few
that even worked on on dogs uh we got
together in a motel somewhere in
Bethesda spent a day or two talking
about the best way to find
systematically to go about finding drugs
that would slow the aging process
um and there was a wide range of
opinions not too surprisingly the mice
people thought we should work with mice
and the rat people thought we should
work with rats etc etc
um
Huber after viewing it hearing
everyone's thoughts
agreed with me and with Arlen Richardson
Arlen and I
were virtually unanimous in how we
viewed the matter and he asked me to put
together a white paper for his personal
use that would explain how one might
design an interventions program that the
Aging Institute could conceivably fund
whose main goal was to find drugs that
slowed the aging process in mice uh we
understood
that finding such drugs would have at
least three important benefits it would
serve as a stalking horse for hopes that
eventually one might find drugs that
worked in people I think that's
a moderately long way off but I think
it's an important thing to remember and
for most people that's the most
important thing for me and I think for
Huber and probably Arlen as well the
other two points were at least is
interesting if we found some drugs that
actually did slow aging and extend Mouse
lifespan that would give us Clues to
molecular targets or how the Aging rate
uh was controlled the most famous of
these I think at this point is rapamycin
a drug that that inhibits a famous
enzyme Tor the target of rapamycin once
the Aging in the Nia ITP had shown that
rapamycin would extend Mouse lifespan
this makes it much more exciting to look
at what tour does how tour is involved
in all sorts of age-associated diseases
whether early or late Life Changes in
Tor might have profound impacts on Aging
similarly every time the IDP discovers a
new drug and we have at least four with
big effects at this stage in a small
number an equal number with with small
ish effects whenever we discover a drug
like that it points molecular and cell
biologists at Targets that they ought to
look at because those apparently are
targets whose manipulation can modulate
the Aging rate
the other the third benefit
of the IDP I think is that it generates
a lot of popular excitement and change
in the in the Zeitgeist the popular
opinion of Aging research one of the
most important
um problems faced by people who are
doing serious aging research is that
most people think of it as a crackpot
science as a field filled with
charlatans people are going to make a
buck by selling you stuff that doesn't
work because the FDA has special rules
to help them sell stuff that doesn't
work without having to prove that it
works
and if you tell people you work and
you're looking at anti-aging drugs they
will look at you as though you were
crazy you are a snake enough salesman
you should please find something useful
to do with your life so the third
benefit I think of the ITP is to try to
put those that stigma behind us if there
is a growing group of respected
Publications in decent journals
replicated by multiple Laboratories
saying you know this drug extends
lifespan and it slows cancer and it
slows Alzheimer's and it slows collagen
aging and eye aging etc etc once that
begins to become part of the public
knowledge part of the conversation then
if you send in a requests to your
Congressman I think you know you should
put more money into Asia research you're
not laughed off of the block that's
going to be a long slow frustratingly
long frustratingly slow process but it
doesn't start until there's a
substantial body of good solid
reproducible peer-reviewed science
showing that by gosh drugs do slow the
aging process I think those three things
are the um
sort of Main
uh uh positive Main benefits that the
IDP has had over the years anyway to get
back to your question once uh the white
paper came out the next step the the
Aging Institute puts together a blue
ribbon panel to write an RFA no no
extramural scientists participate in
this it's just their staff members
then there's a request for applications
anybody in the world can apply three
people got good scores my lab at
Michigan uh Randy strongs at the
University of Texas and Dave Harrison's
at the Jackson laboratory so the three
of us got the first three grants and it
was important I think from the very
start that there'd be three separate
um independently funded Laboratories we
take a very unusual approach to science
uh most people when they get a grant
they are allowed to use that Grant to do
what they think is best for the science
the ITP is much more regimented we have
come up with a standard operating
protocol all three sites do that we get
the same food from the same kitchen at
the same time we use the same bedding we
use the same kind of mice uh the data
are pooled the major benefit of this is
that if a drug works at all three places
uh then we can say you know this
probably does work and it may well work
in your place as well uh if it works at
two of the three places then would
probably that of course and but we say
you know this is worth a lot of thought
this may be a good working drug
but it's still a little uncertain we
need more data to see how robust it is
how strong the effect is in the past
before the IDP the world literature was
filled up with single studies in which
one lab
did it with one kind of mice usually
upsettingly the black six mice and would
publish that and then no one would ever
hear from that drug or that study again
uh it takes once the study is published
three or four years to replicate it and
a lot of money and very few people want
to spend lots of money and four years of
their time trying to get that oh yes
they were right paper the replication
paper so having simultaneous replication
in all three sites is a major benefit
the other major element that was
insisted upon in the standard operating
procedure of the ITP was we'd never ever
ever use inbred mice no black six ever
we use genetically heterogeneous any two
mice in our program share half of their
genes like a brother your brother or
sister shares half of your genes all of
our minds our brothers and sisters in
that respect because they're genetically
heterogeneous we will not trick
ourselves into missing a drug that
usually works but not on black six or in
wasting our time on a drug that only
works on black six if the drug works on
our genetically heterogeneous mice there
is about 100 chance but a much better
chance that it will prove to be robust
over a wide range of different kinds of
mice so those are the central features
of the ITP design uh immediate
replication of three sites these are
genetically heterogeneous mice and
Community participation we don't make up
what drugs to test anyone in the world
could submit one or two or ten ideas
there's a February deadline which year
and then we have a committee system that
looks over those ideas and picks five or
six or seven a year
uh we test them in a short-term pilot to
see if they'll kill the mice if the mice
look great after we give them the drug
for two months then we officially accept
it into our longevity programs and uh
um this way
anyone in the world has a really good
idea about a drug either a drug their
LAB Works on or a process an enzyme that
they think is important they don't have
a hundred thousand bucks to test it in a
lifespan experiment but we do and so we
can uh piggyback on their good ideas uh
and incorporate them into the design of
the ITP
foreign
that was a really great explanation to
the ITP and as you say reproducibility
is a huge problem
um in science and it's great to see that
you do it at free sites as well as
having these heterogeneous mice and as
well as doing it in both males and
females which is also really important
given that as we'll probably get to
there are some specific differences in
your findings oh yeah so I guess yeah
so my next question is just
um what what are what are the most
surprising findings that you've seen in
the study so far
well the most important finding which
I don't think is currently surprising is
that you could slow aging with drugs
I mean by now those of us who pay
attention to this field know that to be
the case but it was not known to be the
case when we began this it was known by
those of us who are paying attention
that you could slow aging with single G
mutants but no one wants to change their
DNA and we wouldn't know how to do it
anyway and if you're willing to lose 40
of your body weight maybe you'd live
longer but no one is going to do that
either so the the real uh translational
Pathway to human preventive medicine is
drugs that you can take with a glass of
water every morning so that's the most
important of the ITV findings that
that's not science fiction that actually
works
then amongst the more specific details I
found them the most exciting original
finding was in the 2009 paper the
rapamycin paper in nature I would have
bet and I would have been incorrect that
for a drug to extend lifespan you have
to start it in young adult life the
earlier you start the more chance you
have to slow and slow and slow the aging
process and if you started it after the
animals are already kind of old and they
already had some you know pre-cancer and
their joints are a little rickety and
they had some endocrinological loss of
beta cells you know then it wouldn't
work anymore and that was wrong because
rapamycin started as late as 20 months
of age that's in human equivalent years
it's sort of in the mid 50s somewhere
along those lines if you start rapamycin
as late as 20 months of age you still
get a full lifespan benefit I think
that's really interesting I don't
understand it exactly I mean what it
means obviously is that there are some
bad things that can happen to you after
the age of 20 months the rapamycin
blocks and then if you block them
lifespan is extended just as
dramatically as if you had started the
rap of mice and young adult life
we've now had data from two other drugs
which are more or less supportive of
that notion I imagine we'll get to these
drugs later but a carbos if started in
mid life gives half the effect that it
does if you started in Youth and the
other one 17 off Ester dial is started
in midlife gives an effect that's very
similar to the same effect you would get
if you started it in youth so as a
general rule the notion that you don't
have to wait that is you don't have to
start with teenagers you can start with
people of a sort of level of seniority
you'd expect of an associate professor
or tenure professor and still get a
lifespan effect
I found that to be substantially
surprising the third point I'll I'll
offer in response to your question we
have two drugs now a carbos and canagler
flows and
which probably work by blunting not the
average amount of glucose in your blood
but the peak daily level of glucose in
your blood neither of these in Mysore
people well at least in mice seems to
modify the average glucose level in your
blood but it sure does move down The
Daily high level the peak level and both
of these drugs extend lifespan and they
both do it in males dramatically one of
them a carbos also works in females a
little bit
now that's a surprise I would not have
guessed that you could
um dramatically increase longevity by
modifying the peak glucose hit there's
something in the body one can guess it's
in the brain but we don't really know
that is paying attention to oh my god
there goes the glucose again oh my God
it happened again and paying attention
to the the very highest levels of
glucose and using that to slow aging or
do normal aging
um I don't know how that works you know
most of our mice are dying of cancer so
whatever it's doing it's slowing cancer
if I was a cancer biologist
I would want to pay a lot of attention
how is it that you can slow down
breast cancer and lung cancer and blood
cancers and a lot of other kinds of
cancers liver cancer that these mice get
by blunting the peak daily glucose level
I don't know of course if it's going to
work in humans but it certainly Works in
mice so that's that's a nice big
surprise any one of our drugs that works
gives us a whole new way of thinking
about the aging process
the last surprise that I'll mention to
you is work that is not ITP work I'm
going to brag about work being done by
people in my laboratory Gonzalo Garcia
and Jenna Lee whose last name is spelled
l-i
they have been working for two or three
years to ask what appears to be a very
simple question are there shared
mechanisms of slowed aging that is
if you list all the things that are
accomplished by one of these slow aging
genes like the Snell dwarf gene or the
growth and receptor knockout Gene you
make a long list of those and then you
make a long list of the things that
calorie restriction does and you make a
long list of the things that rapamycin
does the way carbos does is there
anything on all of those lists and the
big surprise is that yes we have 13
things 13 famous things that affect fat
and macrophages and brain and liver and
muscle which are flipped by four
different mutants four different drugs
and the calorie restriction diet in
young adult mice so these aging rate
indicators I think I hope will become
the sort of next big thing in aging
research because if if it proves to be
the case that anything
that is going to slow the aging process
will have to trip all nine of these
aging rate indicators and all nine of
those tissues
that gives us a way to screen for
anti-aging drugs and it gives us big
Clues as to what kinds of cellular
molecular processes are intimately
connected with delayed and decelerated
aging and the diseases of Aging as well
that's
more novel and it's on the shakier
ground it's you know we have published
six papers but I want to say a lot of
it's confirmed by other labs and there's
still a lot of work to do
wow yeah you just like raised so many
questions and I'm sure we'll try and gay
free some of those points is few
um but just to start with uh rapamycin
as you were mentioning as being one of
the most surprising findings that you
can start later in life and still have a
benefit
um I believe since then you've also
tested different Doses and have you also
now tested a different time periods like
does it have to be continuous treatments
or can it be sort of intermittent
yeah we published a paper a few years
ago in which we tried starting late in
life that is at 20 months of age with
three different treatment schedules in
one of them rapamycin was turned on at
20 months of age and they got it till
they died
in one of them it was turned on for just
three months and then it was taken away
and they never saw it again
and one of them was a monthly
vacillation it would go on for a month
then off then on for a month then off
then on for a month for males all three
schedules worked great they worked just
the same for females that there was a
surprisingly a big difference the
leaving the turning it on and leaving it
on was great for females as it always is
uh giving it just for three months
didn't do a darn thing for them they
so they've never seen it before the on
off on off thing was somewhere in the
middle for the females it was better
than nothing but it wasn't as good as
leaving it on we don't have any idea
really why there was a sexual dimorphism
in their response to these schedules
okay and so as you sort of mentioned
this whole earlier fat from my sin it's
Target's mtol which um I mean it's
involved in many processes from NFL but
one that it sort of promotes is
translation and I think there's Now sort
of somewhat links to some of the actual
biology research done in your lab where
you've shown some sort of work and cap
independent translation and some
potential investigations to understand
why inhibiting mtol might be increasing
the lifespan
yeah
um so those are two two important areas
one is how does mtro work and the other
is what is Cap independent translation
and they they are consistent with one
another but they point in slightly
different directions so most messenger
rnas are translated when the ribosome
Globs onto the cap all the way the five
Prime end and then it zooms ahead till
it gets the start side and then it makes
a protein
but there's a subset of mrnas and no one
knows how big it is that you know a
couple dozen maybe even a couple hundred
mrnas are special and they are eligible
for cap independent translation they're
five Prime untranslated region has a
batch of special modified adenosine
residues the adenosine has a methylation
at the sixth position so it's called
six-methylene
if cap dependent translation is blocked
and by the way rapamycin blocks it then
the ribosome can start on in instead by
jumping to these six methyladenosine
sites that recognizes them with the help
of a batch of other proteins and it can
translate the protein anyway even though
regular old cap dependent translation
has been blocked one of the things that
Gonzalo Garcia found was that the
liverins and muscle and kidney cells
from the long mutant mice actually have
lots and lots of cap independent
translation and then more recently he
found that my son rapamycin have a lot
of that myosin a carbos have a lot of
that and interestingly uh 17 alfester
diol which extends lifespan in males
only Gonzalo found that they have a lot
of cap independent translation but only
in males so it mimics the uh the pattern
of results you see when life span is
your endpoint so of course this doesn't
prove that cap independent translation
is a critical element of the slow aging
process but it is certainly consistent
with that notion and the the it may well
be that the um special set of proteins
which are eligible for cap independent
translation are elevated in most or all
slow aging mice we would love to know is
that true so far all of our data are
consistent with that notion and we'd
also like to know what are those
proteins and what do they do
we have a clue about one of them and now
this is working on work that Gina Lee
has published
special protein and enzyme made by the
liver called gpld1
what it does is there are special
proteins on the surface of most cells
that are tied to the plasma membrane of
the cell by a special sugar phosphate
anchor a
which involves phosphatidyl inositol so
gpld1 Cleaves that anchor and in so
doing it can throw a lot of proteins
that used to be attached to cells it
throws them into this into the plasma
now we don't know why that does the
cells we don't know what those proteins
the whole thing is mysterious but there
was a paper published a couple years ago
by another lab with two really
fascinating findings one thing they
found is that if you exercise gpld1 it
goes up and exercise everybody knows
gpld1 is good for you
and then they found that if you over
Express gpld1 in mice your brain got
good that is cognition was good and also
a protein Gold uh bdnf brain Drive
neurotrophic factor that maintains
brilliant cells and a stress resistant
formation that went up too so that was a
clue that maybe the way exercise is good
for you was it turned on gpld1 and that
did good things for your brain
having read that paper what Jenna did
was look at all of our slow aging mice
and it turns out that gpld1 is up in the
liver the fat and the plasma of all four
of our mutant mice all four of our
drug-treated mice and calorically
restricted mice and for the drugs that
are sex specific uh in some tissues it's
sex specific for gpld1
so the reason I got into this is it
turns out and Gina discovered this as
well that GPL D1 is a cap independent
Protein
that's the link we don't know exactly
why cap independent proteins
are over expressed in so many tissues of
these long-lived mice but Gina's work
that I've just mentioned gives you a
clue one of those cap independent
translated proteins gpld1
has the ability to improve cognition to
improve brain cell turnover and also to
improve brain cell stress resistance so
that gives us and we hope other labs
lots and lots of Leverage for starting
to look at that in molecular detail GPL
D1 doesn't actually get into the brain
and how it is that gpld1 in the plasma
causes the brain to do good stuff
is not known other labs focused on gpld1
are going to have to dig into that but
we don't know the answer
yeah that's super interesting and like I
have a couple of questions to sort of
somewhat follow up with that um firstly
I guess now that you have some more
insight into mechanism does that
therefore lead to more potential
compounds that could either actually
inhibits um
um like alternatively to rapamycin and
then also with this like cap independent
translation is there any link as well
with like immunity and that like viruses
sometimes if they're trying to attack
cells they sort of exploit the capped
pendant I mean because I might be
misremming my biochemistry but
um could there be any link as well with
enhancements of like cap independent
translation and having better immune
response in the cell that's a good
question I don't know the answer
should really look into that uh if maybe
they've done it I don't know the
literature at all well but if it turned
out to be as you were speculating if it
turned out to be the case that some
pathogens some pathogenic viruses turned
off cap dependence translation in
multiple cells one can imagine that
preservation of cap independent
translation might be a cellular defense
mechanism against infection that would
be cool if it was true it may be true
and yeah and say I um have you also
um from this well found any other ways
of maybe increasing the activity of
gpld1 or I guess like generally it's
more common to find Inhibitors of
proteins than activators well this is a
great idea that's that's one of the
things we're doing now that is we are
screening uh chemical compound library
in vitro to say do they turn on gpld1 if
we can find chemicals that are like FDA
approved drugs which put onto cells in
culture turn on gpld1
or even better turn on gpld1 and other
cap independent translated proteins
those chemicals will automatically get a
place in the next set of ITP
applications so far all of the drugs
that the it all the four drugs that we
have tested anyway that are anti-aging
drugs in the ITP they do turn on gpld1
and they do turn on cap independent
translation now the other way around is
what we're going to do with our
screening approach we're going to screen
for drugs that turn on cap independent
translation and if we find some I hope
we will then we'll make an argument that
we really want to test those for
lifespan
okay
exactly
um and I guess maybe this is another
thing that could be looked into is
whether or not there's any sort of
genetic variants either in different
species or within like centenarians that
are like in these cap independent
processes
um to sort of speculate them
yeah I think certain areas are not the
not the way to go because
they're so weird in so many ways for
instance they're almost all going to die
in the next year or two and they've all
had very extensive they're all taking
drugs of one sort or another so it's I
don't think that's the best way to look
at it but in the human population there
are good ways to look at get yourself a
batch of 65 year olds and rank them into
who is the healthiest if you can find 10
of 65 year olds who have great eyesight
great hearing excellent reflex speed
perfect cognition they can still walk
for five miles without getting out of
breath and when you give them a flu shot
they produce tons of good anti-flue
antibodies let's call that 10 the elite
65 year olds it'll be really nice to
know whether they have a lot of cap
independent translated proteins in their
skin or
blood and it would be really cool to
know whether they have a lot of gpld1 in
their blood I would love to do that
experiment
yeah for sure there's a lot of humans
that are taking drugs like I don't know
metformin and can I go flowsin uh and
and see if the drugs
increase
gpld1 in their blood and increase cap
independent translated proteins in their
blood uh back screening
healthy volunteers who are taking any
one of the 20 or 30 most commonly
prescribed drugs might you might stumble
across a drug that did indeed cause that
same set of age aging rate indicators to
increase in healthy young adults or in
healthy middle-aged adults I think
that'll be the
the most straightforward and most
relevant way of starting to ask these
questions in human populations
yeah and since
I named Matt Fullman was tested on its
own and didn't show a lifespan extension
and the ITP study but then when it was
combined with rapamycin you sort of
enhanced effects and saturated has it
been like followed up not exactly when
we it's a little bit complicated when we
added rapamycin and Metformin together
in females
we did not see a statistically
significant increase in females
rapamycin is great adding metformin to
it it's still great it does a little
better two percent or something like
that but it could just be a chance
effect
when you added metformin to rapamycin in
males you saw a bigger effect but it
still didn't quite reach statistical
significance the p-value is 0.06
achingly close to the standard
conventional uh p-value that's a that's
a troubled experiment because we didn't
have a simultaneous rabomycin only group
we were comparing rapamycin plus
metformin to two previous historical our
own historical data sets of thrapamycin
which is always a little risky so my own
view is that it's a it's an up in the
air that if you add metformin to
rapamycin
with a large enough number of mice and
maybe over three or four different doses
you might find an additive effect
however we now have an additive effect
there it's a rapamycin plus a carbos
this is just accepted for publication a
month or two ago
when you add rapamycin to a carbos
remember a carbos is a drug that has a
great effect in males almost as good as
rapamycin actually in females it is
statistically significant it always
works but it's much much smaller in the
males it might give a 20 increase to the
females of five percent increase
always there but always smaller so in
any case when we added rabbit moisture
plus a carbos in the females it was just
as good but no better
than rapamycin by itself however when
you added a carbooster rapamycin in the
males you've got the biggest percentage
increase we'd ever see now at 29
increase in median lifespan is
buying rapamycin to with a carbos so
that's two Milestones the first
Milestone is the one I just mentioned
it's the largest percent increase
we've ever seen in the ITP the other
Milestone is the first time we've ever
seen
a pair of drugs that used together gives
you a greater percentage increase than
either drug used by itself and to a
significant extent so that's that's
important because it's a you'd imagine
you'd hope that using two drugs that
have different targets and different
mechanisms you might get a bigger effect
than either drug
used alone that's sort of expected
that's okay but nonetheless having data
to prove it is a step forward
exactly and I mean since you've
mentioned a car base and also uh
previously kind of chronically phase
them I'm not sure if I'm saying it
correctly but um they're all like I
guess effective um like sort of
diabetics drugs so lower glucose levels
and so so they all I mean I know we've
met four minutes so not entirely cleared
the mechanism of action but with like
category Flows In It targets
slgt2 or SLG T1
um and yeah I guess I was just wondering
in those cases then would it work to use
those in combination as well
um well there's a batch of things to say
about that
um
it's not known how can anglophloxin
works either in my sort okay our
starting hypothesis
which is reasonable
it's working by blocking in the kidney
sglt2
and in so doing it lowers blood glucose
because when blood glucose goes up when
the mice eat a few Donuts or something
blood glucose goes up and it is lost in
the kidney if the reabsorption pumps are
blocked by Canada that's very plausible
idea however
sglt2 Inhibitors and sglt1 Inhibitors
they have Targets in lots of other
organs and it could well be that the
good things that conagraflowsin are
doing are either partly related to
glucose and partly related to some other
mechanism or it could be that the
glucose is just really a tiny part of
the story and that some other Target
tissue really counts in humans clinical
work you know it's a it's a drug that
has been in clinical practice for
diabetes only for a fairly short time
five or six or seven years something
like that but people have begun to
notice that humans taking
can I go Frozen or other uh members of
the family other relatives that block
sglt one or two or both
um they tend not to get quite so much
cancer you know and they tend to get not
so many heart attacks and strokes and
stuff so
um whether it has an effect of that sort
in non-diabetics I think is an
interesting proposition my hunch is that
it does but again more data will be
needed it's it's a whole family of drugs
whose targets and involvement in
pathology are not yet fully understood
and so we don't really fully understand
why it is extending lifespan in mice I
would love to see someone suggest to the
ITP for next year
one or two molecules that block sglt2
only and one or two that block sglt1
only and maybe one or two that block
sglt2 but only in the heart
there are such things because the drug
companies of course are fascinated with
this whole family compounds and they're
making lots and lots and lots of
compounds that are tissue specific or
Target specific I would love to see half
a dozen of them tested by the ITP and
that would help us
discriminate the original hypothesis
it's blood glucose that's doing it from
other hypotheses which are not yet very
well tested
yeah so as you said like these um these
glucose Transporters obviously not just
necessary presence and the intestines
but presents and different tissues as
well and so clearly it's an important uh
membrane protein but half that by any
sort of mouse studies like either
Knockouts Mouse lines without these uh
Transporters or knock down studies that
could also help to validate some of the
intervention testings I think your
question is a good one
but I'll let me say two things about it
it has to be done by Laboratories that
are focused intensely obsessively on
sglt2 so you know what I you don't want
an amateur lab a lab that just does AG
research to be competing with
Laboratories which have 10 billion
people working on sgl2 at either because
they're going to win and they know what
they're doing and they have all the
tools
um the other thing is that knockout mice
and even knock in mice
often will lead you down the wrong path
often knocking it out is lethal knocking
it out in a single issue may not work
because the real effect may be on a
different tissue
um so the sort of default assumption
let's knock it out and see if we get
living forever mice is too simple and it
it occasionally works but much more
often the results are
subtler and involve tissue to tissue
communication to give you one example I
told you about this gpld1 story where uh
JPL D1 goes up and a lot of slow aging
mice including mice that don't make a
lot of growth hormones so we figured
well obviously the liver is not making
gpld1 because it's not getting growth
hormone signals so we did more or less
what you were suggesting we knocked out
growth hormone receptor in the liver
only and we expected to see gpld1 go up
and it didn't that was a big surprise
clearly what's going on in these mice is
that there's some tissue we don't know
which one it is yet
that sees growth hormone or not and then
sends a signal to the liver that says
turn on gpld1
so it's at least two tissues involved in
this the liver which makes the gpld1 and
some mystery tissue that actually
responds to growth hormone
we have at least one example where we
know what tissue it is there's a lot of
stuff that goes on in the fat of these
slow aging mice for instance uncoupling
protein one uh is up in the fat helps
keep you lean it is important in
thermogenesis well it turns out that the
growth hormone receptor in the fat
doesn't make any difference it's the
growth hormone receptor in the muscle
the muscle sends a signal to the fat
telling it turn on ucp1 so that there we
actually found out what tissue does IT
muscle
what molecule goes to the fat it's
called irisin and what it does in the
fat it turns on ucp1 we haven't tracked
that down yet for the liver and what is
causing the liver to make gpld1 we're
going to have to knock out growth
hormone receptor in this tissue or that
tissue or that tissue and see what we
get
so is that mainly how you've been
investigating this this um communication
between the different tissues by using
tissue specific Knockouts or like we'll
sort of like cut like tools that you use
in I think that's a good way to do it
now I'm lucky enough to have a
collaborator guy named John kochik who
made and gave us liver specific growth
hormone receptor knock on mice fat
specific and muscle specific mice so we
have them in the colony and whenever we
get something like this we sort of
automatically try it out on those three
organ specific Knockouts in the fat it
answered our question it was the fat
sending of the muscles sending a signal
to the fat in the question of gpld1 it
didn't it's another Edition which we
don't know about yet and if someone
comes to the lab and really wants to ask
that he or she will have to make brain
specific Knockouts hypothalamic specific
Knockouts macrophage specific Knockouts
and see what they get it's sort of the
guessing game unfortunately
and speaking of the brain I think with
the kind of glyphosan um there was a
pre-prints I didn't quite get time to
fully read it myself but I think you
were looking into
um as um microglia cells and astrocytes
in the brain in response to treatments
um so is there any connection between
um improving uh brain health
um following reduction in glucose
so they're two different Labs working on
this in my lab Gina Lee has looked at
the brain
and looked at two specific markers bdnf
and double Cordon which is a marker of
brain cell turnover and neuron
production and she has found that they
are indeed uh increased which is the
right direction the good direction by a
carbohydration 17 outposter Dial in
males and canaga flowsin in males
now she did not look at glial cells
but I have a former postdoc now her own
running her own lab a woman named
Mariana sadagurski she's an assistant
professor at Wayne State down the road
in Detroit Mariana is an expert on glial
cells and she has found that a carbos
and 17 off estradiol when given to male
mice
prevent age-associated changes in glial
Cell Activation and inflammation they
don't do that in female mice which is
consistent with the fact that these two
drugs have a big lifespan benefit in
males only so Mariana has just published
a paper maybe the one you were talking
about in which she evaluated glial cell
Implement inflammation inflammatory
markers in both I think hippocampus and
hypothalamus uh but she is the the real
expert on that topic and I am more
cool all right I found out
um so given what we've sort of spoken
about and some of the results you found
um what is your current theory of Aging
or do you have a theory of Aging I think
it's the wrong question I think to make
progress in aging research one has to
um stop asking about what is the Theory
of Aging and start asking a closely
related question what is the theory of
slowed aging
so somebody who works in immune function
or all too often will say oh yeah it's
due to in too much immunity you're going
to have autoimmune disease that causes
aging someone who's in the connective
tissue will say yes connective tissue
someone who's into the brain will say
yep the brain they've got to change the
brain to slow the aging process down if
you're into oxidation or somatic
mutation or whatever you're into
whatever your lap does you think that's
the cause of Aging I don't think that's
a productive way to think about it I
think the bad things that happen to all
of us as we get old whether we're a
mouse or a person or a dog they have
multiple causes some of them have to do
with tissue injury that can't be
replaced or oxidation damage or
mutations that cause cancer or
cross-linking in collagen etc etc etc
dozens to hundreds of these things that
are the cause of Aging I don't care
that's of no interest to me what I want
to know is what can slow it down the
really amazing thing which was guessable
as early as the 1930s but is now more or
less unignorable is that you can slow
them all down together you can slow them
all down with at least four drugs in
mice at least for mutations five
mutations if you count P10 in mice and
at least two diets the famous
calistricta diet but also methionine
restriction and amino acid imbalance
diet so since you can slow down aging of
cells that divide cells that don't
divide extracellular tissues feedback
circuits immune circuits since the whole
thing all hundreds of age sensitive
changes can be [ __ ] in parallel the
only really interesting question is how
does that work what is it is that is
slowing everything down in parallel sort
of as a metaphor you can imagine a grand
ballroom with thousands of Lights in the
ceiling and if you wanted a place to get
darker you could send someone up on a
ladder and take out one bulb at a time
or you could go over to the wall and
turn the rheostat and all of the lights
will go down at a time so people who are
working on Aging in the immune system
they're doing one bulb at a time the
immune system or aging and connective
tissue or Aging in the brain I want to
know what the reason where the rheostat
is and how the rheostat is connected to
so very many cellular and acellular and
multicellular and extracellular
age-associated changes
when I got into this area you know at
the beginning of my career it wasn't
obvious that that was a smart play
it could have been most people thought
they may still feel that the whole thing
is too complicated in that you can
really only work on one system at a time
now I think if you're paying attention
over the last 30 years it's become
incontrovertibly clear that you can
change the rate of Aging in multiple
tissues in multiple cell types and it's
easy that is we have at least four genes
and four drugs and two diets that can do
it so that's where you'd ought to spend
all of your attention how is it that
these interventions that slow aging and
postpone so many different kinds of age
Associated diseases how do they work how
are they can what what causes them all
to change together
and what causes all of the downstream
things all the diseases and discomforts
of Aging to be a link not a perfect link
it's it's not a hard steel bar but to be
coupled to the aging process nature
figured it out
um
you know if you buy a big dog a Mastiff
that dog would be healthy for six or
seven years and then get sick you buy a
little tiny dog uh like a restaurant
white terrier that dog can be healthy
for 11 12 13 years and then get sick
nature does this over and over and over
again makes short breeds of dogs and
horses and also can make shorter species
or sorry long-lived species and longer
dogs or horses it's apparently not too
tricky
so I'd like to learn how to do it
exactly so I mean what are your thoughts
then on the fields at the moment at like
kind of as it says
um and what are your thoughts on like um
the different ways of the biological age
measurements so things like uh DNA
methylation and how would that compare
to these other potential markers you've
been talking about
well I'm I'm what we call an
ill-informed skeptic in the area
that is
many of the papers that have been
published make it look as though DNA
methylation is a way of assessment of
multiple age-associated changes in many
different kinds of cells
and they may be right I mean they're
very smart people they're very good
scientists it would be so nice if they
were right however over and over and
over again they reach conclusions that
from my ignorant point of view are far
too good to be true
one reason I think to be
um
very cautious about this is to note that
every year somebody says oh the one that
looked great last year nope mine is
better each year they get better and
better and better so it looked pretty
good four years ago why why is it now
not look so good another reason to be
cautious is I I sort of believe it if
someone said I've got a way of looking
at your muscle liver cells and it
changes between the time you're 20 to 40
to 60 to 80. sure I can
that's reasonable however they say oh by
the way it works in all the cell types
uh really every cell type has its own
methylation pattern and then they say oh
yeah oh and by the way it also works
between birth and adulthood
and now I start to say now there's
something horribly wrong here and then
they say oh forgot to mention it works
in tissue culture this thing we call
cellular aging which is over hyped since
hayflick introduced that silly idea
um they say oh by the way the DNA
methylation thing works in cell culture
too it discriminates Young from old
cells it's at that point that their
alarm bells ringing all over the place I
I don't trust even good scientists if
they're making claims that always seem
to work for them
um I I'm I'm being deliberately a little
iconoclastic here a lot of these people
are friends of mine they know a lot more
about it than I do I send them tissues
all the time because I want that working
uh and many of them are I think quite
skeptical and appropriately so but I did
want to introduce a note of caution it's
it's not I think ready for prime time
yet at the Gordon conference on the
sisters biology of Aging I really
enjoyed a poster given by someone uh
they found that there was a marker of
biological age that you could get from
human blood DNA methylation marker and
they found that when women got pregnant
they got old
until they delivered the baby then they
got young again
and then they found that if people
needed surgery they got old until the
surgery was over and they were back home
recovering and then they got young again
and if they were taking it if they were
grad students they were taking a test
they got old
until the Texas over us they got a good
grade they got young again so it's
obvious that whatever they were
measuring which they were calling over
and over and over again a marker of
biological aging wasn't it wasn't
remotely useful as a marker of
biological aging it's a marker of sort
of loss of physiological homeostasis a
loss of biological equilibrium that's
interesting it's really interesting that
you could detect
many different kinds of stresses
including aging
by modulation of DNA methylation
patterns I think that's really cool but
to refer to it as a marker of the
biology of aging and how old the cell is
and how old the person is strikes me as
sort of
what's the word drug dealers using their
own stash or something like that I think
they need to be a little more critical
and they always give me a lot to think
about I'd say like I'm kind of one from
Nissan what sort of advice would you
give to I guess like younger scientists
um in terms of working out like why they
can have the most impacts and how to
like what what is the best way to to do
science obviously reproducibility is
very important and I mean it's all
demonstrated in the ITP study but what
sort of like generic advice could you
give to younger researchers
younger researchers who are really
really interested in the biology of
Aging is that the question
so I mean yeah any I I guess well or do
you have yeah directly for for younger
researchers the uh
um the answer is and I'm this is not a
genius level answer you have to work
three times harder than anybody else
uh and you've got to really be working
on something you care a lot about
um picking a topic that you think will
get you published in a system where you
can get results fast
that's often a pathway that burned that
burns you up if you don't care what the
answer is I think it's important to pick
a problem that's really really exciting
and then the other thing is I think it's
um
as a footnote important for you not to
believe your Mentor your Mentor is a
famous scientist whoever you are and he
or she is firmly committed with very
rare exceptions to the fact that their
ideas are cool and really good and the
right answers
I think you need to step back over and
over and over again and say now wait a
minute this might not be right there may
be another better way of looking at it
uh many people don't do that they they
decide early in their career that aging
is due to DNA mutations
or aging is due to we get too many
senescent cells or something
and then they do that for the rest of
their lives and they're not interested
in arguments or data uh where someone
says you know it's not actually uh it's
not due either to somatic mutations or
to so-called senescent cells
they don't want to think about that it
would hurt them to think that the last
10 or 12 years of their lives have been
focused on the wrong problem or an
interesting problem
I think you need over and over again to
do that very tough step of saying maybe
I need to rethink this it's hard for
people
yeah never sure
um and so um to kind of wrap up then
what are the sort of main questions or
main experiments that you would like to
be seen conducted
um within the next five to ten years and
what sort of outcomes or like where
would you like to see the fields um in
the next five to ten years
well
my I think the main interesting question
is the one I've mentioned too what what
is it that slows the aging process in
mammals in particular although there are
good hints from invertebrate systems and
there are good hints from uh cross
species comparative biogeratology so
from all of those areas if you if you
read the literature you can easily come
up with 10 or 12 or 15 good ideas ideas
that are not yet disproven some people
say you know NR NAD and nicotinamide uh
metabolism that's a critical thing
others will say actually mitochondria
are a critical thing others will say
it's major changes in the fatty acid
composition of membranes
each of these ideas is pretty good and
the ones I listed are not disproven
there are disproven ideas like the cell
senescence idea but many great ideas are
not yet disproven and I think grabbing a
hold of one of those ideas and becoming
an expert on it is one way to make
progress I personally think as you've
guessed from our entire conversation
that it's necessary to keep all of those
ideas open but to focus instead on the
central Focus what is it that is
involved in slowed aging
regardless of how that slowed process
comes about
and the more drugs we have that's slow
aging the more mutations we have that's
slow aging uh the more leverage we'll
have for starting first to look at a
sort of a checkerboard if here you have
15 things that slow the aging process
and 25 things you've looked at which
ones light up right across the board
once you have a batch of those then you
can take the next step can I find drugs
or can I find mutations that change
those aging rate indicators those
potential uh rheostats in the metaphor
that I was just using and thereby slow
the aging process down I think that
that's the pathway of course that's what
I'm doing so naturally I think that's
the right way to go I imagine others
have different ideas but that would be
my own personal answer to your question
and I thank you for that um and I think
that's a great way to end our
conversation I think we've covered a lot
of topics and it's really interesting to
to how everything sort of fits together
and goes from early observations and the
testing programs they're now doing this
whole molecular understanding and trying
to back up the mechanism which obviously
is also really interesting so yeah thank
you for coming on the channel today it's
been a really interesting conversation
well thank you for inviting me it's a
they said other episodes of
so I hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening